[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi à 9
octobre
des projections des performances et une
exposition samedi la commanderie à
elancourt a fait nuit blanche pour ce
rendez vous du corps humain et est au
rendez vous un bond de 200 ans ce week
end rambouillet va vivre en 1811 avec
napoléon 1er l'empereur profite alors du
domaine en famille de nombreuses
animations sont programmées un danseur
quatre musiciens autour d'une création
in between raconte l'antre-2 celui d'art
différents histoire différente
la création et jouer la semaine
prochaine à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt la commanderie a fait durer
le plaisir ce samedi le site participer
à la nuit blanche un événement culturel
initié sur paris jusqu'à minuit curieux
et passionnés se sont plongés dans le
mouvement et le corps humain regarder
21h elle brillait pour accueillir le
public
pour sa première soirée sous son nouveau
nom la commanderie donner au public des
étoiles plein les yeux faisons-nous
blanche une manifestation nationale pour
faire reconnaître tout ce qui est dans
le domaine de la culture
les acteurs du territoire qui sont en
résidence chez nous mais qui en même
temps développe dans leur parti dans
leur arrêt tout qui développe ce que
représente l'art de vivre et le le
territoire de 50 à une soirée placée
sous le signe du corps humain du
mouvement
un corps humain qui devient
constellation avec sa nouvelle
installation
l'artiste mahfooz espace douanier
entraîne au coeur de la voûte céleste
[Musique]
l'or existent parce que l'être et là au
coeur et interagit avec elle ce qui
m'intéresse parce que elle est toujours
renouvelées elles se comportent de façon
différente en fonction des comportements
du public
c'est vraiment l'intention de créer les
corps stellaire c'est avec la structure
dans notre squelette qui a détecté par
caméra infrarouge arriver à ce que
chacun crée sa propre constellation et
qu'elles sont enregistrés dans un ciel
étoilé virtuel cette nuit blanche
c'était aussi l'occasion de lancer la
nouvelle exposition de l'atelier des
sciences
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 25e
nouveau un haut de solidarité à présent
le 15 octobre prochain au théâtre de la
madeleine à paris free spirit vous
emmène au pays des rêves celui d'un
enfant qui va croiser autant de
personnes bienveillantes que
malveillantes
ce collectif d'artistes a pensé création
dansée et costumés avec près de 200
participants
leur particularité ils sont tous
bénévoles les fonds d'une spectacles
sont entièrement reversés à une
association
sandrine ferrand et rambo liten elle
fait partie de l'aventuré nous en dit un
peu plus on crée le spectacle de façon
sûre le système de la collaboration et
chacun a son mot à dire moi même et tous
les autres et c'est vrai que ça il ya un
partage
voilà qui est dont les résultats et sur
scène et très coloré gai et coloré
variés au delà de faire un beau
spectacle et d'offrir une petite
parenthèse de joie et de rêve comme ça
aux gens au delà de ça on sait que les
tous les bénéfices récoltés vont idée un
orphelinat au congo certains se pressent
devant les grilles avant même leur
ouverture depuis 25 ans le festival de
bande dessinée de buc ne cesse
d'accueillir de plus en plus de
passionnés
cette année plus de 8000 spectateurs ont
répondu présents et parmi eux didier de
bernardi qui ne rateraient pour rien au
monde ce rendez vous n'est que la dendre
il a suffi pour une série au long cours
comme thorgal une paire sa famille part
à sa recherche il a retrouvé son fils
qui disparaît
entre bédéphiles on parle bien sûr de bd
en 25 ans didier de bernardi n'a raté
qu'un seul festival de buts
cette année encore il fait partie des
premiers de la file c'est qu'un certain
difficile des auteurs qui sont
difficiles à avoir qui sont rares et
donc bah il faut être dans les premiers
sinon après on passe la journée pour un
seul auteur didier espère compléter sa
collection il possède plus de 5000
ouvrages
une passion qu'il partage avec des
auteurs devenus pour certains des amis
un regard amusé et attendri aussi parce
que c'est c'est le phénomène des des
gens qui sont vraiment passionnés par le
par la bd et où et didier en fait j'ai
connu lors d'une dédicace au château de
versailles organisé pour le personnel
par un autre gars de fagard de
surveillants je sais pas comment il faut
dire de versailles qui nous avait fait
venir didier est un amoureux des comics
et de la bd franco-belge ce dimanche il
veut rencontrer olivier choix ce
dessinateur français je vais connu par
une série de s'appeler l'inspecteur
bayard
c'était destiné aux enfants qui
paraissait dans okapi et
olivier jeu parce
est devenu le dessinateur un dessinateur
de la série spirou est donc maintenant
il y beaucoup plus connus qu'avant quand
ils disent mais juste l'inspecteur
bayard où c'était facile de le voir là
maintenant c'est un peu plus compliqué
je mettais au temps de crise et d'amour
les algériens aujourd'hui cette dédicace
va rejoindre la collection de didier ce
passionné en possède aujourd'hui plus de
3 millions en 1811 le domaine de
rambouillet est un petit pavillon de
chasse un lieu de retraite privilégié à
l'époque l'empereur napoléon 1er s'y
prélasse en automne de cette même année
et c'est un épisode que la ville la
bergerie nationale et le château ont
choisi de faire revivre un client
neyrolles vous êtes la chargée d'action
éducative du château et ce week-end ça
va être une vraie plongée historique
oui alors l'objectif c'est vraiment
effectivement de transporter les
visiteurs à l'époque de napoléon 1er à
rambouillet et pour ça on a tous
ensemble donc la ville le centre des
monuments nationaux qui gère le château
et la bergerie nationale
on a vraiment voulu créer une histoire
et
effectivement on veut transporter le
public en l'année 1811 une époque qui
est très prospère pour l'empereur parce
que il vient juste de fêter la naissance
de son premier et unique héritier
donc une belle fête à cette occasion et
on peut s'imaginer qu'effectivement
quand il vient à rambouillet ma il veut
profiter de cette famille et de la
naissance de son jeune fils seif qu'à
rambouillet il ya un riche patrimoine
napoléonien quand il n'y aurait
peut-être alors il ya un riche
patrimoine napoléonien et la ville a
voulu vraiment le mettre en avant en
obtenant la marque de ville impériale
justement donc on a le château avec des
appartements d'époque napoléon qui
présente
des éléments vraiment sublime comme la
salle devant de napoléon 1er qui
parfaitement
par un peu d'entrain servait oui qu'on
servait surtout c'est important et puis
il ya ce palais du roi de rome donc
c'est l'ancien hôtel du gouvernement du
xviiie siècle qui a été riche en tournée
qui est aujourd'hui à un mollet au musée
qui a été restauré justement à la
demande de napoléon pour le jeune roi de
rome qui vient de naître
alors à chaque son histoire plus ou
moins ou plutôt son sa catégorie sociale
le château on s'en doute c'est surtout
la cour la bourgeoisie la vie populaire
c'est plutôt du côté de la bergerie ça
sera représentée par les activités
présentes - oui c'est ça alors l'idée
c'était toujours de travailler autour de
cette histoire imaginée napoléon et
aaron billet on a en 1811 dans son
château on va assister à des scènes de
vie quotidienne des initiations de danse
des intermèdes de théâtre de la musique
et puis il y à sa garde impériale donc
c'est vraiment c'est garde rapprochée
qui sont au pied du château dans leurs
bijoux dans le bivouac 1 ils attendent
les ordres de l'empereur et il y a
surtout la grande armée qu'il faut
pouvoir loger quelque part sur le
domaine de rambouillet n'en se dit tiens
il y a de l'espace à la bergerie
impérial aujourd'hui bergerie nationale
et donc on va pouvoir assister à toutes
les écoles de soldats l'école de
cavalerie les écoles ou de tambours et
autres à la bergerie et vous savez
contre l'armée s'installer quelque part
et ça c'est vrai pour toutes les
périodes de l'histoire qu'en termes et
s'installent quelque part il ya une
vraie vie populaire qui se crée un
ouvrage qui fait pour les arcs denver on
se dit tiens on va avoir des fainéants
là donc il ya toute cette vie populaire
qui émergent et qui va être mis en avant
à la bergerie nationale qui dira époque
napoléonienne du costume j'imagine vous
avez dû faire appel à des associations
des professionnels
tout le monde va être costumés alors on
va laisser aux professionnels et aux
passionnés
les costumes alors on à 250 intervenants
costumés sur l'ensemble des sites
donc c'est quand même énorme sont des
gens qui sont passionnés donc il y à des
entreprises mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'associations et puis nous qui allons
accueillir le public évidemment on sera
en tenue d'accueil et de surveillance
pour pouvoir justement les accueillir et
faire la différence entre toutes ces
animations historiques qui sont vraiment
une grande qualité parce qu'on a
sélectionné des associations et des
entreprises qui sont reconnus dans ce
domaine là pour pouvoir surtout
interagir avec le public et échanger
leur passion c'est vraiment le coeur du
sujet s'est transportée dans l'époque
mais aussi d'apprendre et de découvrir
et parmi les découvertes ce qu'on va
pouvoir apprendre cette danse est comme
l époque
oui c'est ça avait une petite
particularité on pense souvent 2014 dont
des bourrages de versailles j'imagine
que l'époque de napoléon il y avait
aussi les codes
alors il ya des codes il ya des
nouvelles danses qui apparaissent et au
château effectivement il y aura un
maître annoncé qui sera là qui apprendra
la famille impériale à danser donc là on
invite le public à se joindre à la
famille impériale pour apprendre annoncé
et à la bergerie may come on évoque la
vie populaire c'est pareil on va avoir
du coût des initiations et plutôt de
danses populaires avec un bal un bal
populaire à la fin de la journée de
samedi il me semble et
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est qu'on
va avoir un autre aspect au palais du
roi de rome ce qu'ils ont fait appel à
la compagnie 12e rab rethel qui va la
présenter des chansons populaires
donc ça va permettre à mende avoir un
aperçu global la riche de cette époque
alors une petite particularité pour les
places il faut passer par une plate
forme mais ceux qui découvriraient
l'événement dernier moment et ce qu'ils
peuvent quand même se présenter ce
week-end oui alors effectivement on
avait on a opté pour une vente en ligne
via ticketmaster de passe qui permette
vraiment d'avoir accès tout au long la
longueur aux trois sites et à côté ça
ben oui toutes les personnes qui vont
présenter le jour j sans avoir été
informé de l'événement et bien vont
pouvoir acheter des billets mais par
contre ce sont des billets qui seront
par site
voilà 10 h 30 billets du château le
biais de la bergerie et le biais de la
ville
merci elle m'a fermé réservé ou les
animations historiques autour de l'
empereur napoléon 1er c'est ce week-end
les 13 et 14 octobre
on part faire un mélange entre musique
et danse isabelle olivier est une
artiste de jazz ifrad ya un danseur de
hip hop leurs rares au premier abord
éloignés se lient le temps d'une
création in between parle de
l'entre-deux du mélange
ils seront sur la ferme sur la scène de
la ferme de bel ébat la semaine
prochaine les colas d'andré pour les
images
[Musique]
c'est la rencontre de deux mondes le
jazz et le hip hop la harpe et la danse
avec une between isabelle olivier ifrad
ya font tomber des barrières à l'origine
un album de la musicienne sur son séjour
outre atlantique
je me suis installé à chicago il ya six
ans et de d'expérimenter cette page
blanche quand on arrive dans un pays
qu'on connaît personne qu'on n'a pas le
droit de travailler comment on construit
un projet artistique et que
effectivement quand on est de deux
continents différents on est vraiment
différent en ce qui me concerne la
lisière ça fait écho à l'entre-deux
c'est un petit peu une situation dans
laquelle je me suis retrouvée de parme a
donc mes racines bien sûr de je suis de
nationalité française mais d'origines
multiples et je me suis retrouvé
d'emblée dans une forme d'entre eux deux
un entre-deux espagnol et mauritaniens
dans lequel il fera dia puis sa matière
chorégraphique isabelle olivier se
nourrit de ces expériences
internationales se rencontrent il ya
plus d'un an
la curiosité puisque aller au centre de
ma démarche en tant que danseur et
chorégraphe c'est-à-dire lé jeu
j'affectionne de me confronter à des
univers différents des écritures
des pensées différentes une rencontre un
duo qui se développe pour in between
trois autres musiciens rejoignent le
plateau qu'on a mille et une facettes
dans ce spectacle il ya des liens qui se
tissent y construisent au fur et à
mesure des jours de répétition entre
chaque musicien et il fera entre des
groupes de musiciens et l'ifra et je
crois que les mille et une facettes
apparaissent au fur et à mesure du
spectacle et que le le spectateur voyage
dans un univers qui n'est ni de la danse
nous de la musique mais un univers
presque extraterrestres ou on perd ses
repères en fait une discussion entre
deux arts qui deviennent universelles
les artistes souhaitant mener des
spectateurs en voyage un appel au
partage
[Musique]
90 artistes réunis dans un même
événement c'est le 14e festival hélium
les parcours d'artiste il expose de
manière collective ou reçoivent au sein
même de leur atelier et c'est le cas de
notre invité patrick pogu bonjour
bonjour vous avez choisi vous d'ouvrir
les portes de votre atelier c'est pas la
première fois et pourquoi
c'est un moment magnifique de participer
à ce parcours et yom parce que on ouvre
notre atelier on reçoit des amateurs
d'art parce que ce sont des gens qui
sont tout à fait intéressés s'ils se
déplacent cd ils sont intéressés et ils
font un parcours qui qui rouge qui
regroupe 90 artistes sur 30 communes et
sur 40 lieux et parce que c'est le parc
naturel inquiet c'est essentiellement
centrée sur le parc naturel maintenant
ça déborde un petit peu sur l'essonne
parce que vous en savez du succès et
c'est cette un moment vraiment important
parce que c'est les gens qui viennent
nous visiter sont pas des contemplatifs
impôts ne sont pas que des contemplatifs
ils viennent ils changent et viennent
pour échanger y viennent pour comprendre
comment on fait échanger sur notre sur
notre sur nos oeuvres et vous car en
tant qu'artiste parce qu'en général un
artiste travaille seul surtout dans la
peinture
j'imagine que c'est important d'échanger
vous vous nourrissez aussi peut-être de
leurs réflexions de leurs
questionnements bien sûr bien sûr et
c'est pour ça que c'est tout à fait
intéressant le un parcours comme celui
ci il
il réunit tellement de beaux sites parce
que les sites sont magnifiques
il ya des ateliers évidemment mais il ya
également des sites collectifs qui sont
tous des promeneurs
la musique comme la maison des bonheurs
et la maison des bonheurs à mag il y
aura deux artistes également
donc c'est toujours un moment tout à
fait sympathique justement ça a commencé
week-end dernier c'est surtout jour sur
deux week-ends est ce que il est curieux
étaient au rendez vous quelles étaient
leurs questions a le week-end dernier
moi j'ai toujours une question qui
revient quête à peu une question bateau
à laquelle je ne sais pas répondre c'est
toujours combien de temps il vous faut
pour faire une aquarelle
bon alors ça c'est comme il me faut
entre deux jours et deux mois je vais
pas j'ai pas vraiment la réponse j'ai vu
que ça dépend du modèle ça dépend du
format de france voilà alors ça dépend
ça dépend de beaucoup de choses
oui tout à fait ça dépend du modèle ça
dépend du format moi ma démarche et sa
part toujours d'un coup de coeur alors
un coup de coeur sur un paysage un
profil une attitude
enfin quelque chose qui esthétiquement
vous vous séduit et puis derrière ça me
suffit pas il me faut une espèce de défi
à relever par exemple je suis allé aux
salles part au salon au musée du train à
metz il ya quelques temps où il expose
des des trains et des locomotives
il y avait des loco à vapeur
extraordinaire est vraiment j'avais
envie de faire une aquarelle sur les
loco à vapeur
mais bon j'avais pas envie d'en faire
une nature morte
j'avais plutôt envie d'en faire quelque
chose de vivant et j'ai eu l'idée un
moment donné donc peut-être un an après
cette visite de travail et la vapeur et
comment faire de la vapeur à l'aquarelle
et ben voila quand j'ai été prêt à faire
un train à vapeur mais je me suis lancé
et c'était un défi un autre exemple de
défi passe par exemple
d'ailleurs nous sommes ceux je voudrais
juste avant qu'on parce que vous avez
prononcé le mot aquarelles c'est votre
technique et vous y rajoutez un petit
plus vous travaillez que de l'eau vous
aimez travailler dans le mouillé ce que
vous confiez l'an dernier parce que
c'est oui il ya trente six façons de
faire de l'aquarelle mais moi celle qui
me séduit le plus c'est lorsqu'on
commence par nier toute la feuille et on
pose des pigments alors on a tout
préparé dans sa tête bien avant on a on
a étudié on a dessiné on a on a
travaillé les contrats à ce qu'on a on a
fait tout est prêt dans la tête ça ça te
dit ça peut demander beaucoup de temps
mais au moment où on va commencer à
mouiller la feuille
là on a à peu près deux heures pour
travailler pas plus
c'est à dire que bien sûr qu'on peut
retoucher un petit peu etc
mais tout sera dit et tout sera soit
soit raté soit réussie en deux heures et
sans cesse avant elle fait partie de ces
techniques
exactement c'est à dire que là vraiment
je vais mouiller tout là toute la page
tout la feuille et j'ai commencé à poser
mais rouge
j'ai protégé les blancs évidemment j'ai
mis mes verres mais jaune etc
et puis ensuite j'ai surtout essayé de
garder les lumières c'est à dire les
blancs parce que les blancs ils sont
purs casser le papier c'est tout
simplement
et alors ce qui était intéressant là là
il ya eu un vrai qu'il faut j'appelle ça
des cas cadeau du ciel de temps en temps
un moment où je m'y attendais pas voyez
cette grande auréole qui quelquefois est
un des fonds dans une aquarelle
mais là ça devenait quelque chose qui
embrassait les quelques fleurs et donc
j'ai gardé ça évidemment
donc c'est ça c'est la technique de
l'aquarelle c'est garder les cadeaux qui
que vous font les pigments avec l'eau et
essayer de corriger les défauts si y en
a et 1 c'est à quoi elle est là quelque
chose de particulier vous savez que en
général
on présente les aquarelles sous un verre
parce que l'aquarelle c'est une peinture
à l'eau donc évidemment c'est
extrêmement fragile donc on est inverse
alors ce ver il a tous les défauts
ce verre il a il ya des reflets il
éteint les couleurs il est lourd et il
se casse au casse beaucoup de verre
quand l'aquarelliste est donc un des
challenges je vous disais moi j'aime
bien avoir un défi un challenge en même
temps que d'accord à la faire et c'était
de supprimer le verre et vous voyez sur
cette aquarelle et bien il n'y a plus de
verts là maintenant trois ans et elle ne
bouge pas du tout donc j'ai il ya
quelques aquarelliste qui vers nice j'ai
pris le vernis de ces aquarelliste qui
ont déjà une expérience et j'ai
développé mon processus parce que le
processus n'est pas mis sur sur les
tutoriels qui sont disponibles et donc
j'ai développé ce processus est
maintenant j'arrive à présenter des
aquarelles sans verre sans rien si celle
ci si j'utilisais un terme un peu
pompeux je dirais que on retrouve la
quintessence de la toile depuis tout à
l'heure on parle entre nous et en
professionnel non vous êtes un amateur
averti oui vous savez des brevets vos
techniques
je suis autodidacte oui j'ai commencé à
faire de lui
j'ai fait du pastel j'ai fait même un
peu de sculptures du dessin bien sûr et
quand j'ai encore angers quand j'ai
touché à l'aquarelle j'ai été tout de
suite séduit par ce que il ya un côté
tout à fait imprévue qui se présentent à
vous et ça aide à la création et c'est
ça qui me plaît beaucoup dans
l'aquarelle merci patrick au but le
temps file à une vitesse alors le
parcours à d'ateliers 2018 se déroule
les 13 et 14 octobre prochains rendez
vous sur le site internet pour ne rien
rater
les rendez vous chez d'autres artistes
ou chez vous même pour tout connaître
on passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
à la merise le concert prévu le 19
octobre est annulée si la décision prise
par l'artiste lui-même disiz la peste la
salle trappistes invite les détenteurs
de billets à les contacter pour échanger
les places où se les faire rembourser
une nouvelle exposition au centre alfred
de vigny à voisins le bretonneux les
clichés de laëtitia guichard ont laissé
place aux oeuvres de brigitte
whitechurch tout est à découvrir dans la
galerie d'alfred dès le 10 octobre
vous avez un talent pour faire rire les
gens vous rêvez de monter sur scène
le prise mais tv 78 organise un plateau
d'humour papilles et julie chaises ont
un message pour vous écouter est ce que
tu aimes rires je ne fais que ça je rit
à gorge déployée type mais il manque
encore des choses dont je sens qu'il ya
du potentiel
et ce qui est super c'est que prisme
actuellement on va faire un plateau
d'humour on va on va les chercher des
humoristes un peu partout qui vont finir
sur ce plateau se donner à voir se faire
entendre
faire rire les gens à aa et ça ça sera
le cap des 100 oui on est dans le bio on
est dans le local on est un circuit
court et même dans l'humour c'est pour
ça qu'on attend vos vidéos vos
propositions de la petite vidéo d'une
minute 2008 trois minutes max hockey
attention au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on joue avec
la foi georges geoffroy jourdain mettons
scène quatre chanteuses lyriques pas de
partition pas de règle de solfège
elle interprète berceuse ancestrales ou
formule chamanique et appelle de berger
extraits jack
[Musique]
l'idée c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]